G1
[Música]
que
[Aplausos]
ela não queira Esse é meu lugar que ela
não quer a esse é meu lugar que eu não
queira o samba é o meu lugar
diga a hora o traje a pé se o caminho e
convide alegria para entrar seja em cima
da laje ou no bojo do Pinho quero ver o
suor só ar quando vou para outro lado
viajo sozinho conto cada segundo para
voltar para o meu samba mobiliado de
madeira aí carinho pois aqui é o meu
lugar que eu não queira Esse é meu lugar
que ela não queira Esse é meu lugar que
ela não queira o samba é o meu lugar e
se vem a estiagem secando as ideias tem
um grande baú para procurar presto minha
homenagem e esquenta as bactérias pois a
chuva não vai tardar e a Depois da
Tempestade
a fartura e é um Desatino para criar ai
ai nossas palavras e rimas o samba é
quem me cura pois aqui é o meu lugar
hoje com 20 anos de carreira 20 anos de
um mergulho em apneia sem volta nesse
universo
simbólico político estético que é o
samba eu posso dizer que o samba é meu
lugar
e o samba é em si um fim talvez a grande
intenção do Brasil grande dimensão de
brasilidade também é um meio através do
qual no decorrer desse o século de
história vó assistir Enseadas podemos
fazer ouvir e é sem dúvida um princípio
o samba é a pedra fundamental dessa
construção frondosa que é o castelo da
música popular brasileira
e eu não quero com isso parecer que eu
sei tudo sobre samba porque eu não sei
Acho até que nem o próprio Samba Livre
eu também não quero dizer que sou dono
do Samba longe disso
eu já me senti inclusive muito o
estranho com quem o samba falava
eu sou um ocupante desse lugar uma
combate bem acolhido acarinhado à
vontade mas ainda assim o ocupante por
usucapião
o início dessa construção lá no século
atrás foi no Rio que a 1.300 km de
qualquer Fronteira Nacional naturalmente
corria para o mar para oceano olhava
para o Atlântico II
é aquela altura capital da Empire
impúbere República e já era salgada
marrenta e rachada a cidade oficial
virava a França Paris uma série de
reformas urbanísticas queria fazer do
Rio uma espécie de Riviera dos trópicos
reformas obviamente cheia a gente
procriações violência
a cidade oficial da transa Atlântica
portanto a cidade Marginal virava a
África ali no contexto da pequena África
todas as tradições das linguagens que
tinham sido trazidas da África para cá a
força sempre convém lembrar estavam
cozinhando esse caldeirão cultural de
brasilidade que é onde eu me banho onde
todos nós ganhamos teremos ou não a
cidade Marginal também era
transatlântica nesse contexto é que o
samba começa a Florescer
é o chefe da polícia pelo telefone manda
me avisar que na carioca tem uma roleta
para se jogar ai ai ai deixar as mágoas
para trás o rapaz ai ai ficar triste e
ser capaz de verdade Tomara que tua pães
para não tornar fazer isso tirar amores
dos outros depois fazer tudo feito isso
vai se a rolinho assim balanço você viu
pelo telefone é considerado pela
historiografia oficial O Marco simbólico
de inauguração do Samba
e os nossos padrões de hoje não sou
muito como uma canção estruturada como
tal é uma espécie de colcha de retalhos
um apanhado uma compilação
é porque a gente entende como samba hoje
também sou um pouco estranho uma espécie
de samba amaxixado pau né é um pouco e a
despeito do fato de ter sido registrado
pelo Donga disse que pelo telefone é uma
criação coletiva então Já começamos a
ignorando o presente contemporânea
direito autoral Além disso é o chefe da
polícia que avisa que tem uma roleta
para jogar na carioca e o jogo era
proibido nessa época
corrupção policial já existia ele também
é Puro Swing pelo telefone é possuíam
dribles do Garrincha no Maracanã fazendo
os vãos caindo por aqui a colar swing
como João da baiana
provável autor não creditado de pelo
telefone
que um dia teve seu pandeiro apreendido
pela Polícia Talvez o mesmo por isso que
avisou da roleta
o João da baiana
já foi o tempo que o pandeiro apreendido
porque o Brasil para quem não sabe foi o
último país do acidente a criminalizar a
escravidão não sem antes criar uma série
de leis discriminatórias
O Senador Pinheiro Machado respeitar
velci hora da República quando soube da
apreensão do Pandeiro João da baiana deu
um pandeiro novo com um salvo-conduto
assinado de próprio punho no couro do
Pandeiro
é aquele nunca mais tivesse o
instrumento apreendido eu
quero Machado é nome de mãe importante
Rua no rio
João da baiana não
o João da baiana é um dos alicerces
dessa construção uma construção civil do
Brasil tudo se vê do mundo todo que se
vê até de marte
lembra do robozinho ô coisinha tão
bonitinha do pai
essa construção que é o samba seria
muito conveniente para mim e confortável
eu dizer Olha como incrível sabe como é
que ele só sim pois por conta de sua
estética sua poética sua Musicalidade é
óbvio que isso tudo foi fundamental
porção vai chegar não chegou mas houve
um momento ali Anos 30 e 40
Brasil de Getúlio embarcando no folclore
do Futuro folclore inclusive em que a
gente está aprisionada até hoje
Oi e o Brasil não se engane chegou a
flertar com o nazi-fascismo no contexto
da segunda guerra mundial Mas acabou
casando com os aliados teve troca de
tecnologia base americana aqui política
da boa vizinhança Zé Carioca Carmen
Miranda Chiclete com Banana e o samba
começou a ganhar o mundo começou a se
confundir metonimicamente com o Brasil
Aí você pergunta fora do Brasil o Brasil
é o samba
Oi e Claro o estado muito espertamente
começou a se valer da popularidade do
Samba àquela altura já um
estabelecimento já gravado no rádio já
tocando nos lugares promoção inclusive
com cursos de samba e patrióticos que
faziam boas o Brasil de às vezes
compositores que nem do Rio eram
compositores de outros lugares do Brasil
como Ari Barroso Mineiro só que eu era
um pouquinho de Brasil Iaiá ou Assis
Valente baiano chegou a hora dessa gente
bronzeada mostrar seu valor
e o samba foi ganhando o mundo e se
reorganizando no gueto também as escolas
de samba que já vi um desde o final da
década de 20 por aí tá bom começando a
ficar grandes
e esse espaço de pertencimento que a
gente novamente associa o carnaval
naturalmente que a Catarse motivo de ser
da escola de samba mas que durante o ano
todo recebe essas pessoas para que ali
tem um ambiente seguro Refúgio onde
possam viver sua ancestralidade e
as escolas foram ficando grande os
desfiles foram ficando populares e elas
começaram a desfilar com samba de enredo
que são primos desse samba-exaltação um
somos que tem um tema só e que fazem
peça em longe a esse tema
E se a gente quer ensinar o samba para o
mundo
e tem que ter a escola não é
Nesse contexto
o samba ali ó driblando esse essa esse
dilema que tava posto entre um certo
preservacionismo e um Anseio de dialogar
com o mundo
e é vai ficando cada vez mais claro que
não há uma resposta simples para isso
e não dá para afirmar Com certeza mas a
minha tese aqui se não houvesse não
tivesse havido a absorção do samba pela
indústria fonográfica ali nos anos 20 e
30 depois o uso político do Samba pelo
Estado nos anos 40 a bossa-nova não
teria dimensão que teve nos anos 50 e 60
o sol lente tamron Love Little Girl From
Ipanema Góes Walking and she passes each
One she passes Góes
[Música]
a Bossa Nova É pode roda pode
qualquer maneira é o Caetano falando não
sou eu mas eu falo é e qual é a
novidade da bossa nova
e o samba essa altura já era Como disse
um sábio Então as pessoas já sabiam do
samba já era um patrimônio nacional e
uma série de compositores de músculos
que tinham formação numa academia
bastante europeizada como ainda é no
Brasil trouxeram elementos novos para
esse samba que já era versado
naturalmente por todo brasileiro
bom então a música de concerto o já se
foram se incorporando e começaram a
criar ainda mais essa esse dilema
suposto entre um preservacionismo e uma
série de globalização teve a marcha da
guitarra elétrica seja já viram isso é a
roubos assim nacionalistas contra uma
estante realização que já era aquele
momento inevitável aparentemente Nesse
contexto a TV começa a chegar no Brasil
o que líder falar para mãe a PV ocupa o
centro da sala das famílias brasileiras
aos poucos não processo e as poucas
emissoras de TV que tinham nessa época
começa a promover festivais de canção
competitivos muito populares que faz com
que muitos compositores que irão
participar desse festivais grandes
poetas começam cada vez mais a ver a
canção popular como veículo para suas
ideias e suas mensagens Isso vai criando
um estofo muito robusto de adensamento
poético para essa canção popular
brasileira e É nesse contexto de
funda-se a n O que é esse Balaio etéreo
que aceita rock Aceita aceita samba
aceita Forró Aceita música Regional de
qualquer lugar não tem muito uma
definição de gênero
Oi e aí tá Victor Mania o gay aqui no
Brasil tudo isso criando esse caldo de
com o tomico entre um círculo que ao
mesmo tempo vicioso e Virtuoso Virtuoso
porque o samba camaleônico como é com
gingado que ele tem eles ocupam nos
Espaços ele ele vai sendo levado pelos
pelos veículos por onde for vicioso
porque aquele saquinho de especiaria que
era uma conexão ancestral ele vai se
diluindo no chá adoçados artificialmente
já um pouco mais aguado para ficar
tolerável para os Paladares embotados
a imagem instante do Samba
é bom pouco antes ainda o que acontece a
ruptura democrática do golpe militar 64
né eu não posso deixar de lembrar
e que se a profunda com as cinco em 68
E com isso as metáforas as imagens vão
ficando mais cifradas para driblar a
censura prévia Pai Afasta de Mim Esse
Cálice
E aí bebê vai se estabelecendo como uma
grande linguagem Nacional destacam-se
três talvez dessa geração de Ouro da MPB
Caetano Gil e Chico que se você
perguntar aí afora Esses caras são
sambistas provavelmente a maioria das
pessoas Vai dizer que não
apesar de que desde que o samba é samba
é assim
Apesar de que o Rio de Janeiro continua
lindo apesar de você amanhã há de ser
outro dia
E aí sim Chegamos nos anos 70
a MPB já estabelecida
Oi e a gente já começa a prever
é uma coisa cíclica de sístole e
diástole o samba vai e o samba vem e
dessa vez ele veio
não dessa construção que estava sendo
forjada ele veio de um soco do fundo do
quintal
Mais especificamente da Brisa que vinha
de uma Tamarineira no cacique de Ramos
uma revolução instrumental estética
poética harmônica uma reconexão
ancestral porque era um parte dos Autos
muitos improvisos o repique de mão
inventado pelo ubirani o banjo
incorporado pelo Magneto
a linguagem da música negra americana
porque as igrejas protestantes já
estavam no Brasil estabelecidas também e
um estado que nega a educação musical
para os seus cidadãos
acabou tendo uma uma um cidadão
musicalizado pela igreja
eu já ia linguagem do vencimento luz do
sol do funk do Gospel um pouco mais à
frente do hip-hop vai se fundindo de
alguma forma essa linguagem do Samba tem
um processo inevitável e não tem uma
resposta para Simples se é bom você não
é não Ele aconteceu simplesmente me
passou você pega Analisa as harmonias tá
tudo ali as influências estão todas ali
mas é óbvio uma reconexão
do Gueto com samba gerou também todo
tipo de preconceito e discriminação
tanto que o termo pagode que na verdade
designava essa festa esse encontro para
falar de música para fazer música para
cantar
e ele foi taxado pela indústria como uma
espécie de divisor entre o samba bom e o
samba ruim o samba perene e o samba que
pode ser tratado de forma extrativista
Claro de uma forma absolutamente
preconceituosa
e eu chegamos nesse caminho da música
popular brasileira que tem no meu ponto
de vista o samba como linha mestra
e eu me vi nessa situação me formando em
jornalismo
percebendo que eu não queria trabalhar a
redação que eu não queria ser pautado
por ninguém percebendo que se é um dia
eu quiser no futuro entender esse
recorte de tempo espaço o conjunto de
canções
e vai ser um recorte muito mais
fidedigno do que o conjunto de matérias
de jornal por óbvias razões e aí durante
a faculdade foi sendo chamado para fazer
as minhas crônicas e o meu jornalismo
através da canção popular como muitos
outros já fizeram no passado inclusive
talvez através daquela música do Tom Zé
que fala ó senhor cidadão eu quero saber
eu quero saber com quantos quilos de
medo se faz uma tradição
E aí lá fui eu ver equilibrado essa
corda bamba que é o samba sem muito medo
de cair porque eu sei que tem essa rede
da música brasileira muitas vezes numa
rede tecida por cordas Bambas inclusive
aí cheguei na Lapa ali no início dos
2000 Vai la paz tá voltando a ser a lá
para uma geração de gente a fimde
descobrir debulhar esse universo esse
Cancioneiro do Samba com a música que eu
faço e com as músicas que eu canto eu
viajo o Brasil todo muitos lugares do
mundo gravei discos Projeção de visuais
toquei muitos palcos conheci ido nos
meus que viraram amigos
professores íntimos meus
tivesse privilégio de perceber que eu
tava de alguma forma fazendo parte de
uma linha que é muito mais do que
simplesmente a história da música
brasileira
e é uma linha que enxerga uma
transformação de um Brasil possível pela
ótica da música
e do ponto de vista da terra quem gira o
sol do ponto de vista da mãe todo filho
é bonito
do ponto de vista do ponto o círculo é
infinito do ponto de vista do cego
sirenia farol do ponto de vista do mar
quem balança é a praia do ponto de vista
da vida um dia é pouco
guardado no bolso do louco Há sempre um
pedaço de Deus respeite meus pontos de
vista que eu respeito os teus
e essa é minha história
é a minha história da música é uma
maneira que eu vejo isso com todas as
omissões ficar bem 18 minutos
todos os privilégios que cabem aqui em
conta a história mas fique você à
vontade para contar a sua
O gato é